you might have noticed but Microsoft's
been saying honestly a lot lately
honestly this deal is way too good to
believe instead of paying too much for
an iPad I got the surface too but don't
tell that happy honest guy that there's
a more affordable surface pro 3 on the
way and not only is it more affordable
it's thinner has a bigger 12 inch HD
screen and a new keyboard cover
yes Microsoft is finally saying this is
the tablet to kill the laptop or replace
the laptop but it's said that before
twice actually the surface is no doubt a
very improved piece of hardware even
with a bigger 12 inch screen the tablet
has been slimmed down to 0.3 inches and
only weighs 1.76 pounds and the screen
has a high 2160 by 1440 resolution well
the bigger screen this is not the type
of tablet I want to read on in bed but
Microsoft wants you to keep this tablet
on your lap the main change to the
keyboard is the larger and more
sensitive trackpad it's more responsive
but still quite small you could also use
the new stylus to navigate the screen
and a neat trick you can click the pen
to launch Microsoft OneNote to take
notes like the other surface pros before
the pro 3 has Intel Core processor
options and Microsoft says the tablet
will last 9 hours on a charge I'll have
to test that myself though Microsoft
says a lot of those changes fix a lot of
problems with the original services but
they also fix the price the tablet now
starts at $7.99 but not with the
keyboard cover that'll cost you another
129 dollars but why a laptop replacement
doesn't include an actual keyboard is a
bit baffling so is the surface pro 3
finally the device that brings together
the laptop and the tablet with no
compromises honestly you should wait for
my review